Rudy Giuliani
humiliated lawyer Rudy Giuliani who once
represented failed former president
Donald Trump is now saying very clearly
and very directly Trump would tell me
takes uh top secret files home with you
take them home with you Rudy we don't
even know if Rudy had a clearance to
look at those files never mind he
obviously should not be taking them home
Business Insider reports Rudy Giuliani
says Trump once told him to take top
secret documents home Giuliani said the
incident occurred just after Trump
became President when he was working at
Mar-A-Lago Giuliani said he did not
bring the documents home
Giuliani says he was at Mar-A-Lago
working on quote vetting some quote very
rich people specifically going through
their tax returns for Trump this
happened right after Trump became
president quote when I was his lawyer I
mean there was a period of time I was
there like 10 straight days Giuliani
said on the Sunday episode of the WABC
77 radio show uncovering the truth with
Rudy Giuliani and Dr Maria Ryan
I didn't take listen to this this is my
training on top secret I didn't take him
out of Mar-A-Lago describing how he
handled the documents he told me oh take
them home with you Giuliani said of
trump I'm not going to take Wilbur
Ross's tax returns home with me I could
misplace them I you know I never ever
ever ever ever knowingly and I never got
caught but I don't remember ever taking
a document Giuliani said he said he
would put the documents in a small safe
at his desk in Mar-A-Lago to be worked
on the next day Giuliani also said top
secret files are quote very very strange
the way they're put together and often
are very small but they contain a lot of
information
Giuliani and a spokesman for Trump did
not immediately respond now put aside
just for a moment take them home there's
a broader question did Rudy Giuliani
have a security clearance throughout his
time
um working in this capacity to even look
at those documents and the answer is we
don't know
um back in 2019 Maguire says he doesn't
know if Giuliani had a security
clearance acting Director of National
Intelligence Joseph McGuire said he
doesn't know whether Trump's personal
lawyer Rudy Giuliani has security
clearance amid questions over his role
in Trump's interactions with Ukraine's
president Maguire said I don't know
whether or not Giuliani has a security
clearance this came in response to
questioning from Congressman Mike
Quigley about whether it was improper
for Giuliani to be involved in Trump
asking zelenski to investigate Biden and
Hunter
uh multiple reports about that if you go
back to that point in time on MSNBC
acting dni doesn't know if Rudy Giuliani
had a security clearance even if you
have a clearance it's not like you can
just be Waltzing in and out and looking
through files and I think this is one of
the important details that should be
added just sort of generally when we
have these conversations about
classified document security clearances
Etc
having a clearance is necessary to be
able to look at a lot of different
documents and files but it is not
sufficient and what's important to
understand and a couple of lawyers wrote
to me about this and explained it to me
clearly this the clearance is required
to even be eligible to look at a lot of
the stuff but in addition you have to
have some connection to it you have to
have some need to know there has to be
some reason some Nexus as to why you and
the document are coming into contact and
with a lot of these issues it seems as
though there are some that believe
if you have a particular clearance you
can just willy-nilly on a whim at any
point in time grab the files that are uh
um in line with that security clearance
with no actual operational or Working
Connection to them you can't at least
not the way the the rules and the law is
written now what was going on in Trump's
White House we know that with Jared
Kushner and some others they they didn't
even really they weren't supposed to get
security clearances but then there was
like an override done and they got them
anyway we covered it years ago we really
don't know what the standard operating
procedure was but Trump telling Rudy
just take documents home is very much in
line with what we have seen and learned
about over those many years are any of
these people ever going to be held
accountable no I mean this is sort of
like a footnote
and uh you know multiple criminal
investigations into Trump Rudy Giuliani
disbarred in some places all these
things this is so comparatively minor
under Obama it would have been
absolutely and totally huge Obama they
would it would be a week on Fox news but
with Rudy and Trump it's just like a
little footnote it's not going anywhere
sadly